hello and welcome to the European
Parliament in Brussels my name is Sarah
shei I'm head of communication and
Outreach at the directorate general for
external policies and I'm here in the
Vox boox of the European parli
to host a discussion today with two very
distinguished guests well the European
Parliament today is hosting a very large
scale event we are marking the 75th
anniversary of the universal Declaration
on human rights uh so today in and
around the parliament we are going to be
joined by a large number of high-profile
Specialists activists human rights
Defenders both from inside the EU and
its institutions and also from around
the world we want wanted to profit from
the presence of some of these guests uh
to make a stocktaking on a situation in
particular in Ukraine I'm very happy to
welcome our two guests who have joined
me to do just that let me introduce them
on my right hand side I have Mr Udo
Bulman he's member of the European
Parliament and chair of the European
Parliament subcommittee on human rights
welcome Udo Bulman thank you for being
here morning and on my left hand side I
have Alexandra matvichuk she is head of
the center of civil liberties in Ukraine
uh this is an organization which
promotes human rights Democratic reforms
and is very active also on issues such
as evidence on Russian war crimes on the
situation of prisoners um this Center
and Alexandra herself uh have received
numerous Awards in recognition of their
work and I will mention just one or two
uh the center for civil liberties won
the Nobel Peace PR prize in
2022 uh and they were also a
representative of the Ukrainian people
who won the sakarov prize which is the
European parliament's annual human
rights award also in 2022 Alexandra it's
wonderful to have you with us welcome to
Parliament and thank you for being here
thank you for
invitation uh we wanted as we say to
make a stocktaking and look at what is
happening in Ukraine at the moment it is
of course a country that has been very
much Center in the work of the European
Parliament and not least your committee
Mr Bulman the subcommittee on human
rights and you very recently traveled to
Ukraine um less than a month ago you
visited ke but also you visited areas
outside K which had been retaken let's
say from Russian occupation you wanted
to meet with victims of war crimes and
Witnesses uh can you tell us a little
bit about that mission your impressions
and what comes next after the mission
for my colleagues and myself s it was of
utmost importance not to only go to Kiev
but also to see people who have suffered
even more and that was the reason why
with the help and the support of
Alexandra and and other friends that we
were able to go to Chev region in the
north of Kiev to see witnesses to talk
to victims and to get a real
idea of what was happening and what is
still happening in the
Ukraine I think War
turns people
unfortunately into
numbers but only if you talk to
individuals to your next
neighbors that suffered so much from
this war of
aggression you feel people you feel the
need of solidarity and
support and perhaps this is also the
first step of Justice to listen and to
understand and we got a lot
of positive things out of our visit on
which we can work further in our mission
in the European
Parliament thank you well you mentioned
indeed that the numbers are very big and
behind every number is is a person is an
individual story Alexandra you've been
working since long before the current
invasion of Ukraine you're you're your
organization has been active since I
think 2007 you were also very active in
eurom maidan which is more or less 10
years ago now uh but more recently of
course you you've had to deal with the
horrific impact of the full invasion of
Ukraine can you give me a snapshot of
your current work at the moment and the
situation in Ukraine when large scale
Invasion started we faced with
unprecedented numbers of war crimes and
in order to respond to this challenge we
United our efforts with dozens of
regionals organizations we built all
Ukrainian network of local documentat we
cover the whole country including
occupied territories and now in our
joint database Tribunal for Putin
initiative we jointly documented more
than 57,000
episodes of war crimes and
57,000 it's enormous amount but still a
tip of Iceberg because Russia uses war
crimes at the methods of warfare Russia
attempts to break people resistance and
occupy Ukraine by inflicting the immense
pain on civilian population so we
document this pain but from the last
year I start to ask to myself for whom
do we document all this crimes for
because as a lawyer I understood that we
face with accountability Gap first there
is no International Court who can
persecute Putin and top political
leadership and high military command of
Russian State for the crime of
aggression and that is why part of our
job is promoting the idea of creation a
special tribunal on aggression to hold
this people accountable and second the
vast majority of these crimes will be
burden of respons ability of national
system and National system is overloaded
so we have to find a way how to make the
national system stronger to be able to
provide a chance for justice for each
person affected by this war you're
referring to Ukrainian national system
sure because we have the international
criminal court investigation and it's
very important but international
criminal court will limits its
investigation only to sever selected
cases this mean that the vast majority
of cases will be responsibility of
national investigators and National
justice system understood um I think
that one thing that has been striking
and remarkable about the situation in
Ukraine is is its mil military
resilience against bigger and better
armed neighbor but how is the resilience
among the population because as you say
people are hurting and everyone has lost
loved ones how do you keep resilience
going in the face of such tragedy the
war probably is the most horrible things
which can happen so I will be honest
it's difficult for everybody in Ukraine
but we have no other choice this war has
a genocidal character Putin openly said
that there is no Ukrainian Nation there
is no Ukrainian language there is no
Ukrainian Ian culture then the Russian
propagandist interpret this and they
openly said to the Russian TV that
ukrainians has to be rather re educated
as Russians or killed and them in the
ground we see how Russian troops
deliberately exterminate all local
Elites priests journalists
volunteers artists how they taken
Ukrainian children and transfer them to
Russia to educate them as Russians how
they ban Ukrainian language and culture
and Destroy purposefully Ukrainian
Heritage so yes it's difficult but if we
stop fighting they will be no more
us yeah um Udo
Bulman you're a chair of the
subcommittee on human rights so
obviously you are very active on human
rights issues not only in Ukraine but in
other places around the world and as we
know there are plenty of conflicts
unfortunately around the world um
Russia's war of aggression I think as
Alexandra just said is also trying to
reduce Ukrainian or eliminate Ukrainian
identity and eliminate its capacity to
act as a Democratic Society with regular
uh Democratic norms and values uh so for
that reason alone I think it's one of
the reasons why in the European Union we
are strongly uh supporting Ukraine
beyond that there's probably broader
lessons for all of us uh what's at stake
in your view for human rights in general
what are what should we be fighting for
what is Ukraine telling us that we
should be fighting for and maybe if I
add to that you know you you're a
parliamentarian you go and talk to
voters uh what if a voter says to you
this is not really my top concern I'm
more worried about money inflation jobs
Etc this is not the reaction that I get
yeah yeah um
in my constituency which is a huge part
of Germany the state of Hessa Frankfurt
Castle Geon the south of uh Frankfurt if
I go to people to journalists and tell
them what we saw they are dearly
interested they fill the local
newspapers with what we have to tell and
once we start to talk I find a
journalist interviewing me on our last
trip telling me well in my house we
welcomed Ukrainian people because we
feel with them so there is a huge amount
of personal solidarity and the
understanding in the country I know best
in Germany but also in other countries
is really really big coming back to the
core of the question what is the
learning story what what can we do about
it well first of all individual justice
has to be brought back to the
communities as good as possible as good
as possible nobody can give you back
your most beloved uh friends neighbors
family
members but where is it possible to give
back recognize crimes and give back
assets rebuild houses rebuild homes it
has to be done my uh personal position
is and political position of the
European Parliament also
including using the assets uh of Russian
authorities uh that we can uh get hold
of uh here in the European Union but
more and Alexandra was talking already
about that this war of aggression
highlights the weaknesses of the
international judicial system that has
to be strengthened where we those
countries in which it is possible to go
after this crimes do it immediately of
course uh in collaboration with
Ukrainian authorities the judicial
system we have to strengthen and to
support the judicial system yes and we
have also to go for New International
modes Criminal Courts International
tribunes whatever is necessary and
possible and useful the most impressing
thing for me
me
is my personal learning story to what
decree human rights are a building block
of the new Ukraine this is what you can
feel while talking to people I saw a
very Vivid Civic Society structures
great people like Alexandra and others
building a new Ukraine on the basis of
human rights on the Bas basis of dignity
on the basis of justice and this is the
European Spirit which we have to support
and can also then this can also be the
learning for us as well no I'm I'm happy
to hear you say that and indeed it is
true that in Euro barometer polls the
support of European citizens for Ukraine
remains very solid very steady um and
and of course we have to make sure it
stays that way um Alexandra maybe a
question on prisoners because this is
something where you have been active
again for many years but in the last
couple of years we've seen thousands of
ukrainians as you mentioned taken
prisoner uh another issue that is very
heartbreaking is to see Ukrainian
children been forcibly transferred
removed from their families uh and taken
away are you working on that and where
do you see the possibility for justice
and
accountability it's a very sensitive
topic for us as a human rights lawyer
years because we can't rely on legal
instrument for current moment to solve
this problem Russia publicly ignore all
Norms of international humanitarian and
international criminal law and refused
to fulfill decisions of international
organizations and we have different
groups of people we have prisoners of
the war it's soldiers of Ukrainian Armed
Forces which was taken into captivity
we have illegally detained civilians and
thousands and thousands of them we don't
know the real numbers only our
initiative is working on the cases of
more than 4,000 people and this group
mean that people which are civilians
can't be taken in captivity they have to
be released immediately without any
conditions without any exchanges but
Russia keep them in captivity treat them
badly torture them and we have no tools
how to release this people and their
family in in dispair because it's very
difficult to know what's going on and
can't do nothing with it and also you
mentioned the children which is I think
a disaster because uh it's the most
vulnerable group of society during the
war and uh these children are re
educated as Russians uh and
um we have the impact of such policy
look into the children who was in
occupied territories in 2014 uh I mean
Lans and danet region which appeared
after Russian occupation for eight years
and how they were brain bushed for this
eight years uh before large scale
Invasion started uh so we try to find
Creative Solutions and one of the way
which we use is our cooperation with
Russian human rights Defenders yes they
have no much influence to the situation
because Russia is a repressive country
uh but for
us in lot of cases they are the only way
how to do something on the ground okay
uh you're here in the European
parliament in Brussels today you'll have
the opportunity of course to meet uh
members of the parliament and I'm sure
other high level people in the
institutions what do you want from them
what's your message to
them my message is very clear well lar
skill Invasion started uh the
international Partners said let's help
Ukraine not to fail and Ukraine obtain
the first weapons to be able to defend
ourself and first sanction against
Russia were introduced into force and we
are extremely grateful because it helped
us to survive but this is a time to
change this narrative Let's Help Ukraine
to win because there is a huge
differences between Let's Help Ukraine
not to fail and let's help Ukraine to
win and for us as for human rights
Defenders the only way how to stop human
right abuses in occupied territories is
to release people who live there
and you mentioned that you worked with
uh the parliament when recently we sent
a delegation to Ukraine uh how do you
see the role of the European Parliament
in keeping uh the struggle alive and
helping Ukraine to win I want to say
that European Parliament and
especially concrete people there play a
proactive role and this is very
important because we can speak a lot
about common values but well values need
proactive position values need proactive
solidarity and we never forget those
people who was with us during this
dramatic time of our history okay Udo
bman maybe the same question for you
from the European Parliament perspective
what can we do what should we do and how
do you think things look as we run up to
European elections in
2024 well first of all uh s and you
mentioned the world is burning yeah
unfortunately in the Ukraine but also in
many other places so one of our most
important tasks at the very moment is
keeping the Ukraine on the agenda number
one for us so that we do not stop with
our awareness so that we do not stop in
collaborating with our friends and
giving support to to them on all
different areas of their needs
humanitarian Aid Health System
reorganizing infrastructure and also
Alexandra said it weapons they need
means for
self-defense because we are in a
critical situation she rightly explained
that to us and we cannot stay uh idle or
silent in this uh very critical
situation Full Stop on that first of all
secondly um of course we have to realize
and that is also a challenge for the
European
Union Putin's war of
aggression brought a new
dynamic in the relationship of our
countries which you have not choosen
which we did not
choose but this
Dynamic enters into a new state stage of
development of the European
Union which we now have to
proactively design in the best interest
of all of us together with our friends
in the Ukraine and others also so we
have to shape a new European Union where
there is space for our friends and that
will be the task for the next next years
and the next
decades absolutely I'm going to bring
this discussion to a close
I want to thank you Alexandra matuk very
much for coming along to talk to us wish
you all the best for your ongoing work
which is so important and I also want to
thank you Udo Bulman for coming to talk
to us ahead of a busy day for you H and
wish you also all the best in your
ongoing work thank you and goodbye from
Brussels